تم اختباري خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع
وتم تشخيصي بأنني مصاب
بفيروس كورونا ، لقد حصلت على
تشخيص إيجابي لـ kovaydin 19
أنا ممتن وشكر لأنني لا
يبدو أن لدي أي من
الأعراض المروعة للآخرين  أنا فقط أعاني من
سعال شرير والذي لحسن الحظ أن أذكره
لأنني طاقم تكتيكي ممتاز ، فأنت
لم تكن تبتلع كثيرًا ، لا
أنا لا أعاني من
ضيق التنفس أو التعب أو
أي شيء آخر يتعرق ليلاً على سبيل المثال
أن بعض زملائي  لقد عانيت من
كل ما عاناه الكثير منكم مع
أصدقائكم وعائلاتكم الآن
أنا ممتن بالطبع للدعم الهائل
المقدم وكل الطاقم الطبي الرائع
الذي يساعدني في التغلب على هذا
الآن ، قد تقول جيدًا لا كل
الكرات أن القضية لماذا ما زلت
تتحدث الليلة ، فأنا مستريح
وأخذ الأمر بسهولة وسأسمح لي
أن أوضح أنني سأخسر الأمر إذا
كان كل شيء بالطبع يصبح أكثر من اللازم ، فأنا لست
أحمق ولا أنا  يا بطل ولكن عند الأم  لا
أشعر أنني بحالة جيدة ، أشعر أنني بحالة جيدة وهناك
أشياء مهمة يجب أن
نتحدث عنها أنا وأنت كل ليلة مثل
النفط السلبي والطريقة التي تتدهور بها
الأسواق وما لا يزال يتعين القيام به
وهذا هو السبب طالما أنني أستطيع و
لا أفهم لماذا لا سأظل
نجتمع في هذا الوقت
ونجري محادثة جيدة حول الجانب الاقتصادي
لما يحدث